problema número 7 en esta gráfica cuando
x es igual a un medio más o menos por
aquí lleva a ser igual a 2
cuando x es igual a 1 que va a ser igual
a 1 la gráfica es simétrica cuando x es
igual a 2 es decir que si yo dibujo un
eje justo aquí en este valor de x igual
a 2 va a ser la gráfica como si fuera un
reflejo de un espejo aunque bueno no lo
dibujé muy bien que digamos pero el
chiste es que este lado es simétrico a
este lado de acuerdo con esta gráfica
cuando x es igual a 3
en qué valor de verdad tener bueno
entonces nos preguntan este valor cuando
x es igual a 3 qué valor tendrá ayer y
estamos una unidad lejos del eje de
simetría 1 a la izquierda del eje de
simetría cuando x es igual a 1 aquí pues
nos dicen que el valor de hess 1 así que
cuando x es igual a 3 que también deberá
ser igual a 1 ya que esto es simétrico
esta parte de la gráfica es simétrica a
esta así que este punto que nos
preguntan va a ser 3,1 y la opción es la
e
muy bien veamos el siguiente problema
número 81 % de 5.000 menos un milésimo
de 5000 es vamos a escribir nos dicen 1
décimo por ciento es igual a 0.001 por
así que es 11º por 5000
- un milésimo
uno entre mil
cinco mil esto cinco mil entre 10 y 500
menos 5 mil entre mil bienes 105 500
menos 5 es igual a 495 que es nuestra
opción de muy bien hacemos al problema
número 9
cuál de los siguientes es el valor de
raíz cuadrada de la raíz cúbica de 0.00
0 064 la raíz cúbica es encontrar un
valor que ha multiplicado por sí mismo
tres veces de este valor y saben que
cuando se multiplican decimales se debe
sumar el número de lugares después de el
punto decimal
si tengo dos números con dos lugares
decimales y los multiplicó el resultado
tendrá cuatro lugares decimales y si
éste a su vez lo multiplicó por otro
número con los lugares decimales el
resultado tendrá seis lugares decimales
bueno que dámelo multiplicado por sí
mismo tres veces da 64
veamos 4x4 veamos por ejemplo el 44
cubo esto 4x4 es 16 16 por 4 es igual a
64 ajá éste no sirve pero debe tener el
punto decimal para que nos dé el punto 0
0 0 0 64 así que el número original debe
tener dos lugares después del punto
decimal mi estimación inicial es que el
valor original debe ser 0.04 veamos
si yo multiplico punto 04 por punto 04
4x4 16 y con esos lugares decimales
tengo que agregar estos dos puntos 0-0
16 y esto lo multiplicó a su vez por
puntos 0 44 por 6 24 por 4 por 14 564 y
tenemos uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis
lugares decimales así que será uno
3 4 5 6 aquí va a ir mi punto y estos
lugares respondo 0
y nos queda el valor que nos están
pidiendo bueno esa es una parte ya
encontramos cuál es la raíz cúbica de
este valor ahora nos falta la raíz
cuadrada la raíz cuadrada de 0.04 y
siguiendo la misma lógica pues esto va a
ser igual a punto 2 veamos
punto 2 por punto 2 va a ser 4 más 12 12
lugares decimales es igual a punto 04
que es nuestro número original
así que en esta ocasión la opción
correcta es la de muy bien ahora pasemos
al décimo problema arturo pone en una
caja boletos con números consecutivos
del 101 al 350 cuál es la probabilidad
de que un boleto seleccionado al azar
tenga un número cuyo dígito centésimos
sea 2
es decir de esta colección del 101 el
350 cuántos de ellos tienen su dígito
centésimo con 2 pues básicamente son los
que van de el número 200
irak y acaba incluyendo el 200
incluyendo el 299 hay 100 boletos o 100
números
cuando números estamos eligiendo cuál es
el total bueno si tuviéramos del 100 al
350 tendríamos 250 pero como estamos
tomando en cuenta el 101 si tenemos 250
así que la probabilidad de elegir uno de
estos números va a ser 100
entre 250 del total de boratos esto lo
podemos simplificar como esto puede ser
reducido a 10 esto 25
esto nos quedan
esto todavía lo podemos reducir eso
todavía no podemos reducir más nos queda
esto 12 esto un 5 y nos queda dos
quintos que es la opción a aquí hay que
asegurarse de tener bien los límites
pues las opciones tienen muchos valores
muy cercanos y esto es para que ustedes
se aseguren de que los límites de estos
números que ustedes están incluyendo
estén bien comprendidos para asegurar se
hagan la resta y el resultado les suman
un 1
veamos el siguiente problema el número
el lunes leo envío por correo ocho
paquetes que pesan en promedio 12 con
tres octavos de kilogramo el maltés
envió cuatro paquetes pesando en
promedio 15 con un cuarto de kilogramo
cuál es el promedio en peso de todos los
paquetes enviados a ambos días muy bien
entonces vamos a escribirlo tenemos ocho
paquetes que en promedio pesaron dos
kilos
12 kilos y 3 octavos y tenemos 4
paquetes que en promedio pasaron 15
kilos con
cuarto lo que tenemos que hacer aquí es
sumar todos los pesos y dividirlo entre
el número de paquetes enviados conocemos
sus promedios así que la suma de esos
pesos 8 por 2 con tres octavos esto es
lo enviado el lunes más lo enviado el
martes 4 por 15 un cuarto y esto lo
vamos a dividir el resultado de todo
esto lo vamos a dividir en el número de
paquetes totales que son 84 son 12 bueno
esto va a ser igual a que lo que tenemos
8 por 12 es 96 y 8 por 3 octavos va a
ser 3
96 3 96 más 3
+ 4 x 15 y 64 por un cuarto va a ser uno
más 60 más uno entre 12
esto es igual sumemos todo lo de arriba
es igual a 160 entre 12 que lo podemos
simplificar a
40 entre 3
bueno todas estas respuestas están en
términos de fracciones así que este 40
entre 343 va a ser igual a 13 con un
tercio de kilogramo que es nuestra
opción
y con esto terminamos los problemas del
día de hoy